[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und bitte nicht
erschrecken hier ist Stefan Netzeband
denn unsere beiden krimi-königinnen Toni
und Natalie sind's heute verhindert es
gibt also wieder mal ein männerdu mit
mir und mit Mirko Kasimir hallo Stefan
und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen Podcast
heute gibt es einen Fall den man als
sehr modern bezeichnen kann erst mal
weil Mirko und ich natürlich total
moderne Männer sind nein scherz beiseite
der technisch gesehen auch modern ist
also zur Einstimmung würde ich jetzt
gerne mal deine SmartWatch kontrollieren
Mirko welche Fitness Daten gibt es da
ähm
okay dann lass mich kurz mal nachschauen
ja da sehe ich gerade ja so viel weiß
noch nicht heute
2960 Schritte
zwei Stockwerke ok und sind
Durchschnittspuls von
65 nee 85 sorry okay also da ist noch
ein bisschen Luft nach oben hast du
selber eingesehen oder ja ich meine es
ist ja noch früher Morgen das heißt ich
weiß eine Runde mit Monika meinem Hund
draußen aber klar ich später noch mal
raus ne natürlich sehr gut aber wir
wollen uns auch gar nicht übertreiben
worauf ich hinaus will ist natürlich ich
glaubst du du könntest diese Uhr
manipulieren wenn du wolltest z.B um
mich zu beeindrucken oder so boah
vielleicht meine ich könnte jetzt
irgendwelchen Quatsch erzählen aber da
du ja neben mir sitzt könntest du ja
einfach auf meine Uhr lunzen und dann
wirst Du sehen was die Stunde geschlagen
hat aber ich logischerweise kann ich mir
vorstellen dass man da was machen können
was manipulieren man könnte vielleicht
Schritte vortäuschen indem man mit der
Uhr ein bisschen hin und her wackelt ein
bisschen rumkippelt aber ja so andere
Dinge weiß ich nicht keine Ahnung was
kann man denn noch machen ich glaube du
hast recht ich glaube aber andersrum und
das ist das entscheidende sind jetzt
diese Zeit sozusagen schon vergangen ist
dann kannst du nicht Daten hinzufügen
als hättest du dann was gemacht also
wenn du drei Stunden faul rumliegst dann
wird das auch so erfasst von dieser Uhr
ja davon würde ich jetzt mal ausgehen ja
also im Zweifel können wir feststellen
Fitness Tracker lügen nicht wisst ihr
und das ein wichtiger Teil unseres
heutigen Falles denn hier hat nicht
Kommissar Zufall ein Mord aufgeklärt
sondern die moderne Technik die Berichte
und Protokolle die wir für den heutigen
Fall hier haben vor uns ausgebreitet die
lassen allerdings zunächst auf einen
ganz üblen Raubüberfall schließen Mirko
fängt mal von vorne an am 11 mai 2021
meldet sich beim Notruf der Athena
Polizei einen verzweifelter
Familienvater namens Barbies ah es habe
einen tödlichen Überfall gegeben drei
Männer seine Morgengrauen in die Villa
im Athena vor Ort glückanera
eingebrochen und hätten ihn und seine
Frau mit einer Pistole bedroht
das müsse sagte der aufgebrachte Anrufer
eine rumänische Bande gewesen sein die
Räuber hätten ihn gefesselt als seine
Frau Caroline um Hilfe gerufen habe sei
sie erdrosselt worden vor den Augen der
elf Monate alten Tochter Lydia die
Räuber seien mit ihrer Beute entkommen
unter anderem mehr als 11.000 € in
Barbies habe sich erst nach einer Stunde
von den Fesseln befreien können die
Polizei Rast in voller Stärke in den
östlichen Athener vor Ort das ist so
eine Willen Gegend der ist auch
Hochhäuser also Reihenhäuser auch gibt
Strand ist in der Nähe und einer ersten
Sichtung der Beamten zufolge drang die
Täter durch einen Kellerfenster in das
Haus in diese Villa ein im Treppenhaus
stießen sie offenbar auf den Hund der
Familie das war ein sieben Monate alter
Husky Welpe in strangulierten sie mit
seiner Leine am Treppengeländer und in
den Wohnräumen liegt als die Polizei
antrifft die tote Caroline Ihr Baby
Lydia und jemand Barbis sind zumindest
körperlich wohlauf in den folgenden
Vernehmungen wiederholt
Hubschrauberpilot Barbies a seine
Geschichte die Beamten zeigen sich
entsetzt auch viele Menschen in
Griechenland und in England wo die
ermordete Caroline her stammt die
Behörden setzen eine Belohnung von
300.000 Euro für Hinweise aus die zu
Ergreifung der Täter führen Caroline
wird beerdigt die Familie und das Land
trauern und natürlich der Ehemann oder
sagen wir statt natürlich lieber
scheinbar in seiner Trauerrede sagt
Babies laut der englischen Zeitung Daily
Mail unsere Lieben sind die wichtigsten
Menschen für uns alle man sollte immer
auf seine Lieben aufpassen und die
gemeinsame Zeit genießen und während er
diese Worte spricht hätte die kleine
Lütte ja in den Arm auf Instagram postet
ihr nach dem Tod seiner Frau noch ein
Hochzeitsfoto der beiden und schreibt
dazu für immer zusammen gute Reise meine
Liebe aber es ist nicht so muss man
sagen dass die Athena Kripo jetzt nur
neben dem Telefon sitzt und auf Anrufe
von Zeugen wartet zum Glück zum Glück
wird sehr gründlich ermittelt sprich die
Polizei sichert Spuren Fingerabdrücke
befragt Nachbarn und Freunde und sie
untersucht technische Spuren digitale
Hinweise sozusagen ein Beamter sagt
später Bares habe eigentlich von Anfang
an unter Verdacht gestanden aber es
braucht erst die Beweise um den Fall
voranzubringen oder eben die Spuren die
fehlen in der Villa finden sich keine
Spuren der angeblichen rumänischen
Liebesbande an Carolines Körper gibt es
keine Hinweise auf einen Kampf das Haus
hat Überwachungskameras aber jemand hat
die Speicherkarten entfernt und zwar
laut Lock Protokoll in der Anlage nachts
um 1:20 Uhr also vor dem angeblichen
Überfall
zweite wichtige Spur war bis Smartphone
zeichnet über den gesamten morgen
reichlich Schritte auf auch in der
Stunde in der der 32-Jährige angeblich
hilflos gefesselt war und herumlag
drittes Glied der Beweiskette der
fitnesstracker an Carolines Handgelenk
ihn trug die 20-jährige Frau auch über
Nacht und er ist noch in der Leiche als
die Polizei eintrifft der Fitness
Tracker zeichnet auf das Carolines Herz
weit vor dem Zeitpunkt aufhörte zu
schlagen den ihr Mann als Tatzeit
genannt hat der Trecker keinen Puls mehr
ab 4:01 Uhr am Morgen des 11 mai 2021
die Beamten konfrontieren Barbies Mitte
Juni mit diesen Erkenntnissen und
verhören ihn acht Stunden lang
ununterbrochen danach gesteht er es sei
ein fürchterlicher Streit ausgebrochen
erzählter Caroline habe ihn verlassen
wollen als die Auseinandersetzung
eskalierte habe ihn seine Frau
geschlagen und geschubst habe sie dann
im Affekt gewirkt danach habe er sich
die raubgeschichte ausgedacht die
Athener Polizei teilt eine entsetzten
Öffentlichkeit mit das ist der Ehemann
selbst war der Caroline erwirbte
gleichzeitig verhält sie ihn weiter denn
die Geschichte scheint immer noch nicht
stimmig zu sein und schließlich fällt
das Kartenhaus des Mörders zusammen
Barbies hat den Mord kaltblütig geplant
und inszeniert und vor allem hat er
seine junge Ehefrau nicht im Streit
erwirbt sondern während sie friedlich
schlief wieder mal das müssen wir als
alte Krimi Podcast haben die werden
langsam sind wieder mal müssen wir sagen
scheinbar super geplanter Mord ist sehr
schnell aufgeflogen wieder mal muss man
sich sagen sein beruhigt als als
normaler nicht mordender Mensch man kann
sich fragen was geht vor in Leuten wie
Barbies a was war das wirkliche Motiv
schauen wir uns doch die Familie noch
mal etwas genauer an Barbies a lässt
sich als junger Mann in England zum
Piloten ausbilden und wie sich zeigt
bleibt er dem Land auch in der Liebe
verbunden auf der griechischen
Urlaubsinsel aloisos lernt er die damals
15-Jährige Caroline kennen trotz des
Altersunterschieds von 12 Jahren bleiben
die beiden in Kontakt vor Gericht
schildert Barbies märchenhafte Zeiten
mit der jungen Frau darunter eine
idyllische spontane Hochzeit in Portugal
die man so wirklich nur in Filmen sieht
weitere Zitate von Barbies meine
absolute Priorität bei allem war ihr
Glück und sie war vielleicht jünger aber
sie war sehr reif und sie reifte schnell
aber die Idylle hat schon früher
vorzeitig Risse wie man später ermittelt
so erleidet Caroline eine Fehlgeburt und
Tagebucheinträge zeigen dass sie schon
während der zweiten Schwangerschaft
ernsthaft über eine Trennung nachdachte
war wie so ein Caroline gehen also den
Weg den viele Paare gehen aus einer
jungen Liebe wird eine Ehe und daraus
irgendwann ein Minenfeld aus Frust und
Streit und als die sehr junge Ehefrau
ihren Mann verlassen will wird der in
seinem Zorn zum brutalen Mörder das ist
die einfache und deshalb wohl auch
wahrscheinlich Erklärung aber Carolins
Vater David hat noch eine viel wildere
und ehrlich gesagt auch spannendere
Geschichte David erzählte der Presse ein
Drogengeschäft habe zu der tödlichen
Eskalation geführt war bis und seine
Tochter sein bei einem Restaurantbesuch
vom Besitzer angesprochen worden und der
habe gesagt für gewisse Lieferungen
bräuchte man einen Hubschrauberpiloten
allen dreien sei klar gewesen dass es um
Drogen gegangen sei das klingt nach
einer guten mafias Story dann würde
Caroline die Rolle der guten Spielen
denn sie rät Babies nicht nur von dem
Geschäft ab laut ihrem Vater droht sie
sogar andernfalls mit Tochter Lydia
auszuziehen und auf die Philippinen
auszuwandern und diese Drohung so Vater
David habe Barbies ausrasten lassen was
auch immer zum Mord führte im Prozess
bekommt der Angeklagte lebenslänglich
und wegen der skrupellosen Ermordung des
Hundes noch 11 Jahre zusätzlich plus
21000 € Geldstrafe ein halbes Jahr nach
dem Strafprozess wurde auch über Lydias
Zukunft entschieden sie wächst bei den
Eltern ihre getöteten Mutter auf also
bei David und Susan Crouch
auch Barbies Eltern Konstantinos und
Georgia a hatten sich darum bemüht
wollten dass ihr Enkelkind bei ihnen in
Athen aufwächst sie bekamen aber nur ein
Besuchsrecht da haben also elektronische
Daten ein Mordfall gelöst und zwar
alltagsdaten wie viele von uns
freiwillig die sie auch erheben lassen
ob der Fall auch ohne gelöst worden wäre
was meinst du mehr kommen ich denke
schon weil diese Art
beziehungsfälle haben wir ja schon das
ein oder andere mal hier im Podcast
gehabt und gewisse Art und Weise in
gewisser Art und Weise gleichen sie sich
und ich denke schon allein dass es im
Haus keinerlei Spuren für eine
angebliche Bande gab die einen Überfall
verübt hat ich glaube das hat die Kripo
von Anfang an ziemlich misstrauisch
gemacht ich habe übrigens noch einen
vergleichbaren Pfeil gefunden also
tatsächlich nur ein man sollte meinen es
kommt vielleicht schon öfter vor aber
ich habe einen gefunden okay das
entspannt mich nicht auf die Folter sag
an also der stammt aus US-Bundesstaat
Connecticut und spielt in einer Stadt
namens Ellington dort wurde die
39-Jährige Conny debate im Keller ihres
Wohnhauses erschossen aufgefunden und
ihr 17 Jahre
älterer Ehemann Richard erzählte der
Polizei ein Mann mit einer tiefen Stimme
habe sie überfallen ah okay wieder ein
Überfall ja da sehe ich dann doch
parallelen okay genau pass auf es geht
noch so weiter mit dem parallelen der
Mann habe ihn also Richard gefesselt und
seine Frau erschossen und zwar am Tag
der Tat um 9:05 Uhr morgens aber laut
ihrem fitnessarmband bewegte sich noch
mehr als eine Stunde lang allein die
letzte zurückgelegte Strecke betrug noch
370 m und das entsprach der Entfernung
vom geparkten Auto dieser Frau bis zum
Fundort der Leiche im Keller also hat er
gelogen absolut und als er damit
konfrontiert wurde hatte auch gestanden
er hatte zu der Zeit schon länger eine
Affäre
meine Freundin war schwanger von ihm und
da wollte Richard offenbar seine Frau
einfach loswerden tja Stefan und was
lernen wir aus dieser Folge bring deine
Ehefrau nicht um
einverstanden und außerdem niemand
sollte unterschätzen wie umfassen wir
mittlerweile überwacht werden können ich
meine du musst ja nicht mal so ein
fitnessarmband haben jedes Handy
zeichnet deine Bewegung auf irgendwie
schmeichelt muss man dann auch dazu
sagen diese Folge schmeichelt wirklich
niemanden ja die Kerle waren zu blöd
einen Mord zu vertuschen und die Frauen
haben nicht gemerkt mit was für Sie
zusammen waren ja ein hartes aber
gerechtes schlusswort
wir danken euch fürs Zuhören wir haben
den Fall erzählt mit Artikeln vom
Guardian wie in die pendeln und das dann
die drogentheorie von Vater David fand
sich auf dem Portal Krieg City times
Redaktion und Script hatten hatte ich ja
sagen ich bin ja eingesprungen also
Redaktion und Stefan Postproduktion wie
immer zuverlässig toll vertont toll
nachproduziert mit den Sound in den Wake
Studios in München also bis zum nächsten
mal euer Stefan und euer Nico